toddlers and tiaras alum kylia posey has
died she was 16 years old
the loss of the tlc reality star comes
weeks after she celebrated her 16th
birthday in april kylia's mom marcy
shared the sad news on facebook
alongside this photo of her daughter she
wrote i don't have any words or thoughts
a beautiful baby girl is gone
please give us privacy as we mourn the
loss of kylia my baby forever
multiple reports claim that she died in
a car crash however no official details
regarding kylia's death have been
released at this time
et has reached out to the las vegas
police and discovery for their statement
when kylian was younger and she was
three she started doing pageants and
she's a pro when she hits that stage
she'll say she's nervous but once she
hits that stage she's a pro
while kylie is most known for her
appearance on the tlc series what's your
favorite part of the pageant um winning
because i like to win
you don't even know what you do with the
money yeah i'll buy candy she also
became a popular gift when her sneaky
grin went viral
[Music]
during her time on toddlers and tiaras
kylie appeared with her mom who helped
her build her skills as a contortionist
i had kalia and i started stretching her
at a month old just like little legs
like this and then julia about three and
four months started doing her back good
girl breathe okay five nice okay ever
since then we haven't stopped and over
the years she's kept up with her
pageantry i left the band hatches people
everyone sit down sit down
most recently taking part in the miss
teen usa washington pageant kylian has a
very good talent i mean just completely
amazing i don't know anybody that's a
competition for kylian